Arby what are the pros and cons of
artists networking on Twitter and
Facebook well I think you know the
obvious thing is access you know we live
in an age digital age where you know 10
15 years ago to go networked with
somebody you had to be either at an
event or well you have to be at an event
really or you had to live in an area in
LA or New York or London let's say where
you know the people that complemented
what you were trying to do in your craft
or available to you but in you know the
digital world and with the advent of
social media you could reach anybody at
anytime now your approach matters of
course you know the way that you
approach these people it means
everything you know but you could reach
you know if you're a screenwriter and
you want to reach a manager if you're a
filmmaker you want to reach a producer
you know it's it's there it's available
to you at any time it's just you know
very very much a matter of approach well
speaking of which approaches that are
conducive to a relationship and some
that are not well I think the hey check
me out Hey look at me approach never
works we see it in crowdfunding all the
time where you know people will say look
at my campaign they do it's the same
message to everybody that's spamming you
know they're going down their list if
they're following a list and hitting
every single person up with the same
response and to me that's akin to
walking into a crowded room where you're
going to go Network and walking up to
everybody and going into their screaming
into the air Hey look at me oh hey give
me money that approach never works it's
the same thing with you know just social
media that's not a crowdfunding what
you're just trying to cultivate a
relationship I think a good approach is
asking questions you know you want to
give first and then kind of ask second
you know everybody hasn't asked and I
like to say that everybody in this world
has something they're looking to
accomplish everybody has goals okay even
the person that you're approaching has
goals they're looking to accomplish
something so how do you complement them
what can you give them what can you
offer them and maybe it's something as
simple as hey I saw your film if it's a
producer let's say or a filmmaker really
enjoyed it you know why did you decide
to shoot wide in that particular scene
you know in something engaging
something that that makes that person
feel like they're not just getting that
you're not just trying to get to them
okay a lot of people you know when it
comes to social media they see a large
follower account or a lot of likes or in
stage 32 for example a lot of a lot of
people in a person's network and they
immediately think oh like you know I
have to get to that person and the
approach is waving and screaming and
that you know it doesn't work I always
say you treat your online networking the
same way to treat your real-world
networking and what I mean by that is
that if you weren't gonna walk in up to
somebody at an event and say hey look at
me well don't do it online either if you
want to walk up to somebody and say hey
you know I'm a big fan or hey you know I
really enjoyed what you did with this
I'd like to introduce myself this is
what I do I you know I think that's okay
but it's always to me it's always about
giving first you know giving something
to that person first and usually I like
to say give first second and third
before you ask for something in return
so let's say a young filmmaker wants to
launch a Twitter account its first day
they've come up with their profile name
and what their bio is going to be what
would they start tweeting about maybe
they're planning on a crowdfunding
campaign a year in advance
what would be some things well I think
the first thing they need to do is make
sure they have a completed bio it's the
biggest mistake that people make on
social media is they they don't complete
their bio let everybody know what you
know and it's okay to be cute and quirky
but if you're really looking to
accomplish something you have to make
sure that you're putting it out there if
you're an accomplished if this filmmaker
this hypothetical filmmaker is a an
accomplished filmmaker let's say or
somebody that has done something before
you know I was the director of this
short and here's the IMDB link or if
you're on multiple social media accounts
I like to say that you should close the
circle and what I mean by that is within
every social media bio you're adding the
links to those other social media
accounts so that people can get from one
spot to another and you're closing a
circle of everything that is you and
it's a big mistake that people make so
that's the first thing I would suggest
is that you know you really you have
your bio and your very comprehensive
what your bio you use all the characters
and use all the space you can and that's
probably the one area where it's okay to
be the narcissist as well you know let
people know what you do if you have a
place to you know upload a resume upload
the resume place up little clips make
sure
uploading clips use the features the
site offers the social media platform to
your advantage okay the second thing I
would say is that you want to go out
there and you want to let people know
again what you've accomplished you want
to target people that you feel in the
situation - hypothetically you threw out
as far as crowdfunding is concerned for
example I you know you're gonna
cultivate relationships you're going to
crowdsource hopefully three to six
months before you start that campaign
you want to be out there marketing
before you start that campaign that's a
big mistake that a lot of people would
crowdfunding make is that it you know if
you build it they will come and never
works okay you need to create your
audience or build your audience first
let me really need to identify your
audience you need to engage your
audience and then you need to move your
audience and that takes time and so from
day one I would say have a target list
of people that you want to follow people
that you think are going to fit in with
what you're looking to accomplish and
what I mean by that it's not just making
the film maybe it's the subject of the
film you know if you're making a film
that you think a certain group or
certain individuals would relate to you
know if it's a hobby kind of thing maybe
it's something within the story that you
know maybe the main characters a cyclist
then you want to go after the people in
the cycling community just for an
example you do that and you start
cultivating relationships with them so
that when the time comes and you say
okay the film is now up on IndieGoGo
would you please not only support it but
would you please go out there and carry
the message of what I'm trying to
accomplish to other people and if you
call the very relationships you'll get
people to go you'll get people to move
for you but it all starts with
cultivating those relationships and
making sure you're cultivating those
relationships and let that begin to it
again it would ask me questions and
offering information and posting good
material and maybe writing some good
material as well and reposting other
people's material and things of that
nature
being a collaborator as opposed to a
broadcaster
you